okay hey everyone its Mike Matassa and
welcome to the special presentation on
user submitted questions about order
flow and the order flows trader software
and Delta scalper software as well so
you know these are just questions that
have come up over the last last couple
weeks you know I get the questions here
and there usually I just try to reply
directly to a to the user and I tried to
save them on a file and you know once in
a while I try to make a video on it just
so you know in case you got the similar
question you know you'll see your answer
but before I jump in brief disclaimer
and this should actually be question
zero why do you have a disclaimer why
are you wasting my time well it's
because you know you got to realize risk
is involved when it comes to training
and you know and there's money involved
in training and you know you shouldn't
be trading if you can't afford to train
no I mean that said you know training is
not only for the rich and famous you
know you know just be aware that you
know you can lose money when you trade
you know I I don't want people coming in
thinking that you know what I'm selling
them is some silver bullet that's going
to solve all their problems and turn
their PC into a cash machine know that
that's not at all what order flow is
about order flow is about reading the
market and understanding and making your
own trading decisions so this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or making any
other type of investment decision
futures train contain substantial risk
and it's not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all in
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only a risk
capital should be used for trading and
only those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results
alright that's out of the way so
question number one again there's no
order to these you know these are just
questions and I've just been saving them
up and putting them in there so should I
use four hundred percent as the ratio in
determining a market imbalance well you
could use whatever you want but you know
400 percent seems to be the industry
standard by by most traders and you know
when you're talking about market
imbalances right that's these numbers
you see on the order flow chart either
red for sound imbalance or blue for a
mine imbalance and on the order flows
trader you can adjust it you go to the
most trader when you pull up the
indicator and it's right here 400 if you
want to make it you know 300 you change
it to 300 you want to make it 600 you
change it 600 you want to make it 1,000
you can change it to 1000 okay boom now
the other choice you have is this
imbalance of volume threshold so on this
particular chart I have it set at 1
normally I like to have it set at 50
this is a British Pound so I know the
volume is not as big as the e-mini x' so
you know if you set it at 50 you're
gonna get you know a minimum 50 Lots has
to trade for there to be an imbalance
registered so if it trades you know say
3 Lots against 49 and it's set at 50 it
won't show the imbalance if it's set at
10 if you got you know 1 against 11 it
will show up so it depends on if you
want to you know put a volume threshold
on it or not as well so again you know
what you know do you want to use 400%
again you know that's the industry
standard it seems most people use 400%
but doesn't necessarily mean everybody
uses 400% I know one person that uses
1000% I know some people that use 6
hundred percent you know it depends on
your trading your style of trading and
you know how you trade with imbalances
you know some people you know the whole
methodology is based around imbalances
so you know they're looking at specific
things and you know it's up to you if
that's something you want to look at and
again you know just going back to that
volume threshold you know say you only
want to see you know I just showed you
the minimum now you could actually you
know there's people that want to see
imbalances if it's over a certain amount
like say in the e-mini z-- if they only
want to see imbalances above two and a
half thousand Lots okay then you said
two thousand five hundred in that
imbalance volume threshold again I know
people that have you know that's part of
their trading methodology is specific
numbers and imbalances specific volume
so again it did as a you know to answer
the question should I use 400 percent
that's your starting point okay that's
where you begin now here another
question I trade currency futures what
is considered
Delta and what an above-average and how
do you determine that actually I left
out the part he trades euro currency
futures okay and so you know when you
and you're trying to determine that
okay what you do is you look at a chart
you know kind of chart I mean I can't
say you know average Delta should be 300
okay but if you're trading you know a
five-minute chart it's you know it's
gonna be a lot different than say you're
training and eight range chart so for
example here this is Japanese yen I'm
gonna show you how I determine average
Delta well I know on an eight range
chart you know average Delta is on a
currency like the Japanese yeah an
average Delta is anywhere between you
know 50 and 200 you know once you start
getting above 200 to me that's that's a
strong Delta anything less than 50 if
it's from plus 50 to 0 from 0 to minus
50 that's sort of this area that I
consider it to be kind of neutral in the
sense that you know sometimes it can be
you know a difference of one or two
trades you know they the Mart the market
was moving a little bit quick that
doesn't mean I discount it you know I
just keep that in my mind when I'm doing
my analysis it's like this bar here he's
got a delta of 3 positive 3 you know I'm
not reading too much into that Delta
there because to me it sort of falls
into that area where it's kind of
neutral I said if there was another four
Lots on this bid right here or traded
eight then it would be you know it'd be
a negative Delta of minus one so you
take that in my know some people say I'm
like you're on crack but that's that's
how I approach it but okay so compare
that right that's the euro currency it's
an 8 range mostly for currencies I look
at 8 range charts for most currencies
you know British Pound Aussie dollar yen
euro currency and you know compare that
to I don't have a good I said just
opened my charts here so this is the
Japanese yen that's not a 15-minute
chart a 15-minute chart you can get a
huge number sometimes because you're
gonna get I mean this this is not a good
example because it's it's 2:00 in the
morning Chicago time right now and you
know it'd be better during the day when
you got more data but you know as you
get out size Delta's you know 800
you know 400 you're seeing just bigger
numbers coming in you know when you're
using you know say a 15-minute chart as
opposed to an eighth range chart you
know you can cover a lot more ground on
a 15-minute chart then you're gonna
cover on an eighth range chart in a bar
let me see if I got a five-minute chart
here I'm not sure if I still got it I
might have a let me just run through
them really quick yeah I know I I got a
lot of charts open I really like to push
the limit on computing capacities but
you know I got I got a minute based
chart but unfortunately just a bar chart
so but anyway you get the idea okay so
you look at the markets try and find an
area that you would consider average try
and find an area you know a range that
you'd consider above-average try to find
a number you know for me anywhere
between 50 and zero either plus or minus
50 to zero is is what I considered a
neutral so anything above 50 to about
200 is average anything above 200 to 250
above that is above average number three
where do you place your stop okay well
it depends how you're training honestly
it's it's not an easy question to answer
so just pull this up really quick so
this is the Delta scalper okay where do
I place my excuse me just blow this ups
because here's a signal right and okay
well first of all this this trade right
here and it's it's this market is not
moving very much right now so each look
at this each tick you know I trades in
half ticks so you know if you're getting
short off of this this signal here right
you're getting short at 77 it trades up
to 79 do you are you using one tick or
you want to use two ticks again it's up
to you I I like that I sort of hide
behind the high of the signal bar where
you got the signal or they're using one
tick or two ticks again is is up to you
you know in this case they traded one
tick past you know from 80 notice that
the 88-78 and a half to 79 you know
which is right here so the high of this
bar is seventy eight and a half it did
trade 79 if you're using one tick right
behind it you're stopped out you know
again you know I personally like to hide
you know give it a tick or two you know
if you used one ticket we stopped out
and then you'd have missed this move if
you use two ticks and we stopped out I
know some people like to hide behind
swing highs yeah and to me that's a
little bit too much risk you're putting
on I just prefer like a tick or two
rather than you know a swing high or
swing low you know if it's not gonna
work out it's not gonna work out so that
that's you know that's how I would
approach stop placements now you know
another way I approach top placements is
by actually using the the actual
footprint chart right so let's see here
this is the buns so if I have a signal
all right to get short on something for
example or any sort
thanks for example this stack sound
imbalance okay where would I place my
stop it well it would be right above
this level you know say I was getting
short you know off this bar for whatever
reason off this bar okay I would
obviously place my stop initially above
this the high of this bar but then as
the market starts moving down and I'm
trailing my stop I would use the pointed
controls right because if I assume if I
take a position I don't say I assume if
I take a position that the markets
starting to trend down I'm gonna use the
point controls as my as my resistance on
the move lower you know and like on this
on this stacked imbalance you know I'm
using the high of this bar you know as
my area for my stop so if we trade you
know up to fourteen so the high is
twelve
you know if we get up to fourteen I
probably don't want to be in that trade
anymore I'm not gonna be placing my stop
up here at 21 the high of the day no
definitely not you'll read the order
flow for your stop placements do I look
for retracements back to V WEP no I
don't because you know I thought people
I found have distorted the use of V whap
and basically turned it into a moving
average you know I read it there's I was
reading some guys post on Facebook you
know he's he uses a thirty-day V web I
mean what's the I don't know I said I
think that's not using V you have the
way I was taught how to use view app as
a traitor you know going back to last
century you know you know before the
turn of the century 1999 is they use it
as a measurement of trade execution
right you have an order okay and in
order is to buy 3,000 emini S&P s over
the next five minutes okay you buy it
you compare what your execution is to
the view app for that time period so you
start executing it at 8:36 takes you 5
minutes to do it you finish at 8:41 you
Bloomberg you can type in B whap and
I'll let you enter your time periods in
there so yeah enter 836 start and at
8:41 you see the view app whatever it is
I don't know 21:30 five point six six
seven and you either beat it you got a
better average price or your average
price is worse than it now and that's
how you compare if if you executed your
order at at a fair price and you know as
a trader you don't want to be losing to
view app so to speak you don't want to
be consistently buying higher than V WEP
now you know I see people using V web
you know they'll say oh you know we're
trading above the V web for the day
well you know V web volume weighted
average price now you got to realize if
you know as the trading day goes on V
web will tend to flatten as you're
putting in more volume over the course
of the day so if you're using the entire
navy whap it's gonna flatten and then
moves that you have late in the day you
know it's gonna move further away from V
web a lot quicker and you're not
necessarily going to get retracements
back to V web late in the session you
know after one o'clock Chicago time you
know over the last two hours and
obviously at
you know that the cash close you get a
crapload of volume coming in and you
know it's just personally I don't think
it's a good good way that good way to
trade now you know I know if you've ever
read what is it a hedge fund Wizards or
something like that there was that guy
Benny from spear leads I actually had
the pleasure if you wanna call it a
pleasure cut I'm getting yelled at that
guy but nice to work at Dean Witter and
you know he's to deal a lot with his his
trades and my gosh that guy you know
he's not joking when he when he talks
about you know how rough he was on the
guys on the floor you know I said he's
he can literally berate you but you know
he talks about you know using v WEP now
in that time you know granted when he
was doing that that was back in the
early nineteen the mid 90s early 90s
okay and you didn't necessarily have the
you know you had overnight trading but
nobody paid attention really that much
to what happened overnight you know you
would trade the big it's only trading
big snps at the time there was this was
before emini so you know the volume for
the snps overnight was was it it just be
like a couple thousand contracts that's
it right and then during the day huge
you know the volume for the snps would
be a hundred fifty thousand so you know
the you wouldn't even be too concerned
about VF from overnight but now
everything's you know you put in good
volume overnight it training
environments change so you know really
for looking for retracements back to V
web ID I'm not a big fan of it I'm not a
big fan of you app trading indicators
but that's me you know I mean if some
people have told trading systems built
around view app more power to you you
know the way that I've always used view
app is contrary to how people are using
V Webb today and that's just my opinion
you know I mean you know I've got what I
like to look for in markets and you know
don't let me decide you but you know
understand how view app is used and how
it's calculated and if you're using it
as you know a measure you know
understand that during the course of the
day you know
if you're trading you know a contract
and you know two thirds of the day is
done in terms of volume yeah these are
is view I'm gonna move very much no it's
not so you know excuse me keep that in
mind okay single print sound extreme the
automatic buys or sells again now if you
use my software you'll notice that
single prints are highlighted in the
footprint chart and it's no where's my
mouse it's not some magic thing it's
just there to highlight to me because
you know when you're looking at charts
okay and if you've got you know more
than one chart open okay and I know most
people have got you know I hate to say
multiple charts but you know four maybe
six and I know people those screens are
cheap nowadays and you can buy you know
you can buy really nice screens for very
cheap prices you know people got you
know literally I don't know they're
looking at twelve different charts and
you know a lot of the tools that I got
are there to signify you know things so
like this is a single print here it's
two Lots right anything between one and
nine is going to be a single print and
what does it highlights to me that you
know there's there's our single print
there and what does that mean that means
there's price rejection right because
there's no more selling into this bit
here there's only two Lots that trade
and you know is it automatic by you know
generally yes if it's not an extreme
this is not an extreme I don't know if
there was one here I I did I want to
consider that an extreme I extreme I'd
consider you know I'd say a high or a
low let me just see if there's a better
chart somewhere here with like a better
example again I said I just started my
software pretty recently that's just a
regular bar chart just bear with me here
okay
euro currency you know those this is
crude oil
you know it's hang on a second okay so
okay here's would you come back you know
just for example purposes am I gonna
consider this an extreme you know we had
to move up here I got five got another
five here you got five so these are
single prints boom boom boom it's it's
it's designed to draw that circle that
rectangle around it red for you know
downbar green for a nutbar to highlight
it to me to say hey idiot don't miss
these things I like to get it with other
signals you know is it automatic buy or
sell nothing is automatic unfortunately
when it comes to trading because no two
situations are ever gonna be exactly the
same you know I like to get it I like to
see it and then I like to see things
confirming it in the order flow you know
like here okay so you're at this high
and what do you got you got all Delta
it's all negative here I could just see
it in here and I don't have you just
pull it up okay here is it's all just
that negative I mean you got all one you
got a five okay but other than that it's
just all negative Delta you know when I
see these single prints you know I treat
single prints as price rejection you
couple that with negative Delta you
couple that with something like the
Delta scalper telling you hey you know
it's shifting to demand from demand
driven right we had just gone gone up I
mean from down here to up there you know
use it in conjunction it's not by itself
a trading system but it's a tool to help
you with your analysis so you're getting
up here you know okay you've seen signs
of price rejection you're seeing the
negative Delta you're seeing the Delta
scalper coming in telling you that it's
it's changing from a supply driven
market or demand driven market to a
supply driven market that's how you use
it not just take it as other single
print get short no not like that okay
I'm confused about something when you
talk about divergences what's it exactly
what is it exactly is it the change on
deltas and the correlation between Delta
and price open close no it's uh
let me get a chart here okay so Delta's
right
i sorry divergence delta divergence so
what is there's two types there's Delta
divergence buyer there's Delta
divergence sell a cell and is this is
the cell right here it's
this and you call it red triangle right
you got a new or equal hi right here
this green line is my eye that's all
that's how I can tell it's a new high
for the day then you got negative Delta
that's it
right you have it down you have new high
and a negative Delta now my software the
order flows trader software takes it a
step further right
I want also the price action and the bar
to be down you know I don't want to be
taking a divergence sell on an up bar
you know on a green candle as the
markets still moving up because you know
normally this would be a divergence this
is this this bar right here is a green
candle and we got negative Delta and
it's a new high technically that is a
divergence now I know order flows trader
software my software as far as I know
I'm the only software that does it is if
it's gonna give you a sell signal the
bar has to be red you're not gonna get a
sell signal on a green bar why because
if the markets still moving higher you
know it can move higher on negative
Delta you can have negative Delta in the
market go higher people will say well
how can you have market go higher if you
have negative Delta well if you have
bidding coming in you know buyers are
working bids here I'm supporting this
market sellers are selling into it you
could have end up with negative Delta
and that's actually a bullish sign so I
want things to be negative you know I
want the negative Delta I want the bar
price action to be down and I want the
new high you know that's for me on my
software that's how I define the Delta
divergence know I said you know a lot of
software this would be considered a
divergence but it's a it's an up candle
right so I'm not interested and I'm an
interested in I'm down candles now this
other bar here you have positive Delta
and an equal high there's no divergence
here so you don't see this over here
this is something else but the reason
why is because you have positive Delta
okay so that's how it's figured out
which is basic right so new or equal
high and with negative Delta that would
give you a divergence sell divergence a
bi would be opposite a bi would be
annuity cool low with positive Delta it
doesn't you know there's no other fancy
calculations in there it's got nothing
to do with the open closed
of the bar or correlation between deltas
and the price open close no it just
takes you know is it a numerical high
yes okay is that one that's one
condition Matt is the bar you know is it
a red candle if it's on a high or a
green candle if it's on a loan okay is
that condition met and you know what's
the Delta you know is it Delta positive
or Delta negative that's how it's that's
how it's calculated now this one is kind
of sore point do your indicators like
Delta scalper have sound alerts you know
when I say it's a sore point is because
you know most people nowadays you know I
said you know personal computers
training computers are relatively
inexpensive and hang on a second
sorry about that this is interrupted for
a second so when I say you know this is
a sore point right what I mean is you
know if you're trading more than a
couple contracts a couple markets rather
and everything's got sound alerts it's
gonna get very confusing when the
markets start to move and you know I say
that because I've you know I've worked
in places where I literally am managing
you know whole books you know books from
the US or books from London trading
books and you know people would send me
a file on Bloomberg okay here's all the
alerts would be 60 freaking alerts in
there and you know the tsunami happens
in Japan and boom every alert in the
border book goes off and you're
scrambling to see you know you get
pop-ups or you hit sounds and you know
you you heard fast market and you're
just closing them you know it's it's I
find it just you know I said if you're
trading in one market on one timeframe
okay sound alerts is probably going to
be useful to you but if you start
trading you know ESPYs your trading SOPs
on a four range target 10 range chart
you got a one minute chart you got a
five minute chart times that by bonds
five years crude oil euro currency next
thing you know you got 20 different
alert levels you know things that can go
off and you know you'll take the first
one and often you'll you'll miss the
second or third one and you know it's
it's to me I just find it
counterproductive okay now some people
I mean nasty nasty thing oh you have a
sound alert file name here it doesn't
work your software isn't complete well
you know we had this in there you know
because we're going I was going back and
forth with the programmer do we want it
do we not want it if you want it I'll
put you in touch with my programmer I
have done this on several cases and you
know you work with my programmer you
know the charged jewel is a small feed
to enable it you know I don't know if
he's still interested in doing it for NT
7 for NT 8 he might be interested but
again you know it's if you're trading
you know one or two markets ok
don't be personally I don't like to have
it you know should I have it as an
option in there yeah I could I just
didn't you know cuz I that's my own
experience and again you know my
indicators are based on my own trading
experience right right I don't take
other people's ideas and pawn them off
as my own so that's why I don't like to
use the sound alerts is because the way
that I trade I just don't find a useful
period okay that's me you know throw
your stones at me whatever call me all
the nasty names you like but you know no
so the answer is do they have sound
alerts no and again you know that's if
you're using one indicator say you've
got you know Delta scalper price
rejecter and you know one or two other
indicators and they all got sound alerts
the next thing you know like I said you
got 20 different charts open three
different indicators all sudden you got
60 potential alerts going off is that
what you want maybe I don't know I said
but if you're just you know if you say
you're just a crude trader you know
trading an eight range chart that's it
that's all your trading okay maybe it
might be helpful to you I admit in that
case it would probably be helpful I'm
just saying from my own experience and
how I trade for me it's not helpful it's
another question why isn't my chart look
like yours all my ratios are blue uh-hum
and you know let me let me pull up the
thing pull up the chart really quick
this is this this is a question I mean
it's kind of a redonkulous we don't kill
this question but you know it is
question that came up okay so here it is
this is you know these are the ratios
right you got blue
you got black ones blue ones black ones
you know the red the it's a down candle
if the red candle the ratio appear on
top if it's a green candle it'll appear
on the bottom if it's a doji candle it
won't appear because you know for me for
order flow I personally find doji
candles bars that open and close at the
same price level for me in my own
analysis I've read them as kind of
neutral but so exceda you know there's
blue ones there's black ones there's
black ones
there's blue ones blue ones are the ones
that are actionable black ratios black
numbers aren't just the average order
flow going through in the market and you
know so the question was you know hey my
chart doesn't look like yours why you
know all my ratios are blue I want to
refund your software doesn't work well
the reason is you didn't take the time
one to read the the the user manual or
you know understand that what ratios are
you know I've got a what I call racial
bonds hi a racial bonds low ratio bonds
high indicates price rejection ratio
mountains low indicates price support
and the number twenty-eight number 0.699
so if it's above twenty-eight for a
racial violence high you know be blue if
it's below 0.699 anything between point
six nine nine and zero it will be blue
okay if it's a zero point seven it'll be
black if this comes in at twenty seven
point nine it'll be black again are
these lines in the sand no they're not
they're our ratios and you'll take them
in context with the markets your
training these are the numbers that I
use for all markets actually so you know
these these are my guidelines I actually
used to use twenty five I used to use
one but you know I've sort of refined it
over the years to 28 and 0.699 not that
doesn't mean to say that if you know the
number is you know just write on the
board or say it is 0.7 right like this
is 0.51 it's blue
so for 0.7 does that mean all you can't
take the trade no of course not you
could look at it use your brain and
decide you know do I want to take that
trade so you know again you know just to
come up with with another question a guy
sentences your chart doesn't work okay I
want a refund then he says all I got is
on my screen as white okay well you got
to Center your chart right
like for example go there you know
where's Japanese you know you know he
sends in the chart you know where we're
trading in this orders chart looks like
on a Japanese yen you know at the handle
that price axis is you know eighty seven
seventy all you gotta do is press this
to Center your chart and it pulls it
back in you know sometimes the chart
runs off the screen or you know first
time you open your chart it's not
centered properly you Center it period I
mean I mean you know sometimes you know
people I hate to say this but you know
they don't want to just take the next
step I mean yeah I understand you know
sometimes you need hand-holding on new
things but you know part of being
successful in any line of business is
you know whether it's trading or whether
it's working at McDonald's you know if
you work at McDonald's you see fries or
a low you go make more fries you see the
ketchup dispensers out don't wait to be
told hey you fill up the ketchup you
know take some initiative and do it you
know but okay you know I said if if if
you're the person who doesn't want to
feel the ketchup you know we're probably
not gonna get along very well
you know but if you're the person that
wants to take the initiative and learn
things you know I get a lot of emails
from people saying hey you know I like
your software you know look at it this
way you know let's look at it this way
you know giving me suggestions you know
that's what it's about it's about
exchanging ideas you know rather than
just sitting back and you know being
being told what to do you know so I
don't know you know that's just personal
issue personal thing I said traders need
to be naturally inquisitive right and it
doesn't mean you want to take a part of
watch and put it back together or
something but you know at least try to
learn the software learn what you're
looking at it's a lot of information but
you know if you spend a little bit time
of each day I mean you have to jump
right in and you know learn everything
there is to learn about order flow but
you know rather you know just you know
ask you know ask yourself questions you
know what's happening when you know you
come down right like here you sold off a
little bit now you
some aggressive vine you got a stack
buying imbalance what does that mean
rather than just flipping through the
book okay well I got a stack mine and
balance you know the best traders are
the ones that see things happening in
the market okay and try to figure out
why it's happening and understand it I
mean that's what trading is about you
know to be successful I mean the most
successful traders understand what's
happening in the market they don't just
take a signal without understanding know
why it's happening right it's not like
oh hey there's this you know I'm
supposed to buy because you have a stack
mine imbalance well no you know they
know that it's coming down you know we
have the swing high we're coming down
you got some aggressive buying coming in
and you can see how this move is
short-lived Hilton it but you know if
you're just taking said hey I got a
stack mine and balance here market shot
up okay but then it failed well why did
it fail well look at the volume in this
bars it's pretty light you know you have
stack mine imbalance zero against eight
zero against ten zero against twenty
nine so you know there's just sort of a
snapback and it's probably gonna be
short-lived and what happens is the
market sells off and you know it would
have gone and stopped you out you know
had you gotten long here you know this
is why you know when you're talking
about imbalanced volume thresholds right
if I had this one set at 50 these
imbalances would not have shown up I
have this one set at 1 so actually if
it's zero against one it'll show up
because it's zero against one it's just
you know that's just the way them the
computer programmer reads it computer
program reads it rather but you know
zero against eight zero against an zero
against 29 to me that's that's too light
to have a nice stacked and balanced
really you know I set it to 1 the volume
imbalance threshold as opposed to 50 on
this charge is because you know
sometimes you know it could be 25 37 42
I would probably like that imbalance you
know but again zero against eight zero
against 10 tell me that I'd probably
just discount this buying imbalances
being a strong buying imbalance are you
in the next question are you indicators
compatible with bloodhound we're working
on it we're working on it problems I'm
an Asian of the guys in bloodhound are
in the US and for me to be able to talk
to them I have to do it late in the like
you know midnight time
my time and it's it's not easy for me
because I got three kids and and a wife
who thinks I'm the devil so haha anyways
no comment on that but yeah well I'm
working on it and I want to get
everything compatible with bloodhound do
I still have a trading room no I I've
shut it down for now I don't know if I'm
gonna reopen it it's you know a ninja
trader is going through a lot of changes
and they're really you know I don't know
it's it's one of those things where you
know do people get value out of it I'd
rather you know make videos for you know
for everybody and post them online so
people can watch them when they're free
because you know not everybody could
attend a trading room and not everyone
watches the replay
so maybe what I might do for members I
think is create Members Only recordings
you know which would be different than
the recordings that that you see on the
on YouTube but we'll see but right now
the training room is is not open and I'm
not sure if it's going to reopen so you
know those are the ten questions so you
know if you want to learn more about
order flows you're interested in my
software you go to order flows calm when
you go to Delta scalper dot-com to you
know read more about it so thanks and
you know I hope I didn't offend anybody
in this video but you know I trying to
ask answer these questions
some of them might I think are you know
kind of basic stuff but you know he's
basic for me but you know if you're new
to order flow and this form of training
it may not you know it may be new to you
so you know sometimes I I forget that
you know people are new to this form of
training and I sort of you know you take
it for granted that people know stuff
and and they really don't and it's just
you know what what to do you know that's
why I try to create these videos so to
be easier for me sometimes you know to
answer them in an email or create a
video I don't know which is easier but
again you know for people sometimes you
know they're afraid to email questions
because they don't know me but most of
these questions came from people that I
already know that are using the software
but you know I said it's it's one of
those things and yeah another question
I offer free trial no I don't offer free
trials so don't email me asking for free
trials I think get angry at me they
don't give you a free trial I don't give
anybody a free trials anymore so it's
just too hard to manage all these these
user IDs and who's paid for things and
who's not so thanks everyone and bye bye